the book that shook Washington and ended
the relationship between President Trump
and Steve Bannon hit stores at midnight
despite cease and desist orders to keep
it from publication this morning author
Michael Wolfe was very appreciative of
all the free promotion from the
president and his lawyers what I say is
is where do I send the box of chocolates
you think he's helping you sell books
absolutely I mean and not only is he
helping me sell books but he's helping
me prove the point of the book the White
House Calls fire and fury a work of
fiction mr. Trump says he authorized 0
White House access to Wolfe and never
spoke to him for his quote phony book
it's full of lies misrepresentations and
sources that don't exist
look at this guy's past and watch what
happens to him and sloppy Steve back to
that new nickname in a moment but first
Wolfe challenges the president's
interview denial
I absolutely spoke to the president
whether he realized it was an interview
or not I don't know but it certainly was
not off the record I did he spoke to him
at the White House after he was sworn in
I spoke to him after the inauguration
yes and I had spoken to I mean I've
spent about three hours with the
president over the course of the
campaign in in the White House so my
window into Donald Trump is is pretty
significant why don't we see if Sarah
Sanders can settle it we said they spoke
once by the phone for a few minutes but
it wasn't about the book they had a very
short conversation but he never
interviewed the president about the book
he repeatedly begged to speak with the
President and was denied access and he
makes it sound like he was sitting
outside the Oval Office every single day
which is just not the case this is a guy
who made up a lot of stories to try to
sell books and I think more and more
people are starting to see that his
facts just simply don't add up okay
Kimberly before we get your take on the
recent developments I'd like to ask you
about the new nickname
where do you think sloppy Steve ranks in
the hierarchy of Trump nicknames I don't
think it's as good as like Pocahontas
Bryant egg it's pretty good pretty good
because it conjures up the image of like
a sloppy joe get a big messy sandwich or
like something that I don't know it's
that's not right right doesn't it but
it's not something I'd be happy with
Steve Bannon because it just suggests
sort of a slovenly disheveled appearance
so it's it's not shall we say a charming
affectionate nickname not the best one
and Geraldo you were kind of mumbling to
yourself when we were listening to the
sound bite about the access that this
guy got and kind of ridiculing the fact
that he only got three hours in the
course of what nine months it's it's
more than nine months because the
campaign began in 2015 so what you have
is three hours but that is not three
hours of Michael Wolff speaking with
President Trump or president electron or
candidate Trump that's him being in the
presence of Donald Trump the man that he
absolutely analyzes as if he were a
shrink and says things I have to say
that yesterday my wrath was directed at
the Benedict Arnold
Steve Bannon who absolutely has behaved
traitorously to the family that
entrusted him today I really and I don't
generally like criticizing reporters but
Michael Wolfe said something that I
think begs exploration and analysis
Michael Wolfe said and I'm Cody 100% of
the people around Donald Trump senior
advisors family members every single one
of them questions his intelligence and
fitness for office really and every
single one of the family members of this
is a patent lie this is absolutely
untrue and at some point even people on
the Left have to admit as The Washington
Post did today when they questioned that
whether he got access at all under false
pretenses everyone watching has to
question every single one of the
presidents of family so Ivanka who
Michael will say was dumb as rocks she
questions the Ivanka questions the
intelligence and fitness of her father
for office this is not true and it
is unfair it is it is so screamingly
inequitable to accuse the president of
being someone who lacks intelligence
that fitness for office and then say
every one of his own family agrees with
me the author I think you know for a
fact that they don't think that I
probably you know that it is untrue it's
riddled with a lot of dishonest
reporting and we've pointed to some of
those examples but they did let the Fox
into the henhouse Dana yeah for a long
time so they do share a little
responsibility for this
salacious report yeah I mean it's one of
the things that he said this morning was
that he kept waiting for someone to say
why are you in this meeting and it's
just inconceivable to me that this
actually happened in the first place
that's true but remember at the very
beginning they didn't have a White House
communications director it was unclear
who was responsible for what and Shawn
Spicer's role was not only press
secretary but also communications
director it's impossible in my opinion
to do both and to do both well if you
don't have people there that are looking
out for you and they really did a
disservice to the president like so ever
whoever decided to let him in and then
no one was able to say wait I don't
think we should have him here they think
maybe I didn't even know I maybe they
thought that it was just part of the
show that said I think that he wouldn't
have access to the West Wing if he
wasn't granted it you can't get in there
it's like we can't just walk up and
bring the door we can't leave Ben and
grant him that kind of carte blanche
can't Steven by hanging with me me and
Mike you know here we are hanging out
together well I think they thought it
was positive one of the things that
Michael Wolfe did leading up to the
election was to write a couple of pieces
that were very flattering about
President Trump saying how intelligence
he how intelligent he was and how he was
going to be able to pinpoint what the
American people wanted and how he was
able to win and so that was one of the
ways that he got his foot in the door
and and again I don't I don't blame him
and then he writes this book and I've
heard a couple of things also that
aren't really factually wrong like one
thing about Mitch McConnell there's a
report in there that he declined to take
a meeting because he needed to get a
haircut in his office says that's
ridiculous that never happened the one
thing I think that is a little bit of a
danger is
he says he says and I don't know if
he'll reveal any but he has notes and
recordings and contemporaneous reports
and so if you were one of those people
that thought you were talking to him off
the record and you get burned in this
book you might be really cautious about
saying it never happened because then
you'll be super more embarrassed it's
better to just let it go and try to move
on so how damaging is it correct I don't
know when he said he was in Trump's
presence for three hours I think he was
talking about three reruns of The
Apprentice
he was watching in his hotel room what a
prefer I this is a preferable problem to
have let's compare to two situations
Hillary has a book out telling everyone
why she lost Wolf's book is telling you
what happened after Trump won which book
if you were Donald Trump would you
prefer to have okay so I mean I think I
would take the victory book who cares
by the way Democrats you laughing at
this stuff you're laughing at all this
stuff that you're reading about about
him being impetuous impulsive a child
how does it feel to be beaten by
somebody like that who had less
knowledge less knowledge in the
specialty of the expertise of your
candidate your politician got beaten by
a non-politician Queens salesman
salesman from Queens Pete that's
hilarious okay and I want to go to that
in your face I want to go through the
also just the epiphany the big juicy
gossip here because I think Jesse and
Geraldo and I will understand this the
big juicy gossip here is that Trump is
like a child we are all that every man
has been told by their wives or other
wives that we are children no nope nope
men are children if he had meant
generally who are are who want things a
certain way who are impatient you know
who don't have time to even read in fact
just tell me what I need to know we act
like children I am reminded of this
every day in fact that's a compliment
because my white baby
I mean look yeah you would say you say
about me you would say something worse
like I'm the child from the omen or The
Exorcist so I think it's anybody is this
anybody who's his supervisor who's ever
boss they know everybody beneath you
says crap about you because they're
supposed to it's a release as in when
they're it's a changeover when there is
a change when a team in a pre-season is
undergoing a change in personnel because
they lost and now they're getting new
people in theirs although there's half
of those people that are just
grousing they're just saying I hate
they're the guys that go they always end
up going and and then the other people
stay ok there's chaos in a change of
personnel this is all normal and all he
did he got in there and got to watch it
and he said yesterday's why was he
allowed sort of this unfettered access
to like walk around fly on the wall
listen in over your conversations I mean
it's really to me unbelievable that
nobody actually said hey buddy
take a hike I do like dr. Evil's glasses
though that's your nickname for wolf one
of the things is what have we all
learned this week never cooperate with a
book especially if you're in the middle
of an administration if you actually
have something going on it will never
turn out well how about just ever years
ago when I was deputy press secretary
one time I was Karl Rove spokesperson
amongst other things but he was one of
my responsibilities and a reporter
well-known from a very liberal magazine
came and they said you know I think Karl
gets a bum rap and I'd like to do a
profile piece that talks like Karl's
great I'm super smart and see I was
charmed right I went to the White House
communications director I said I'd like
to give him a shot and Dan Bartlett said
knock yourself out and I pulled out all
the stops
interviews third party backup brunch I
did everything
this piece ran it was the meanest thing
I have ever read in my life and it was
my fault
the other thing have I've never spoken
to him after so they seduce you and they
tell you everything you want to hear and
then they get in and it's a hatchet job
yep see I just want to say one thing
about what Dana mentioned about
recordings and so forth I in my opinion
during the time he's in the White House
I don't think he can have a recorder on
him particularly I think that that is
very on your phone but you I know you
can do it but I don't
I think this guy's much more of a smooth
creates well I think I think you're
right
yeah at Michael's the restaurant today
and he's the worst kind of friend don't
tell him anything he's not a friend
don't believe this report that just came
out this afternoon I'm sure that they
are hearing this but I don't believe
that it's true what actually just put
out a report that said you see Bannon
was thinking about putting out a
statement that disavowed the book and
his quotes but the president's statement
beat him to it and therefore he didn't
do it that's action I don't believe that
I don't believe that he was going to do
that because there were hours and hours
that elapsed between that book coming
out and the president's statement and if
you want to get it in front of it and
not cause a problem
he obviously delayed that he didn't do
it but that's one of the things that was
said that he was working on it then they
started issuing the statement and said
forget it what I think I think why not
do it right away way too bad that's the
best he could do the next day because if
there are tapes he cannot say or
disavowed that he didn't do it or he
didn't say it he didn't make all of
these comments he knows himself if he
said it right and if in any way shape or
form this guy has it on a recording he's
screwed the best thing you can say is
the president is a great man
the next thing Bannon is screwed
regardless its speaking of could you
imagine if a reporter like Michael Wolfe
of Gaza was inside the Clinton White
House in the 90s I mean could you
imagine would a reporter watching the
girls go in and go out and what was
going on in the Oval Office what kind of
book this is nothing those are the tapes
that we definitely just came out about
the Hillary Clinton campaign the
Politico book remember the two the two
authors and shudders you shattered and
then the Clinton campaign was furious I
guess how dreary because it talked about
all of them speaking badly about each
other about the candidate and these
things happen and you can get through it
right well the he's the president's
given it so much attention in the books
now could it be a number one gust so he
regrets that for better for worse